how you doing internet creatures i'm
dave rubin this is the reuben report
direct message
for today june 24th 2021
do me a favor subscribe to our youtube
channel
click that notification bell maybe just
maybe you're going to see our videos
in your feed probably not but try
you never know you just never know
what's gonna happen uh guys this is a
huge week not only is it my birthday on
saturday
but tomorrow i'm interviewing
donald trump yes that's right
interviewing
the former president donald trump it's
going to be completely uncensored will
all of my accounts be blown offline
tomorrow
we shall find out uh of course if they
are
all deleted or demolished or exiled
whatever you want to call it
uh i still will be at
reubenreport.locals.com and my full
unen unedited interview with the
president will be there and by the way
i normally don't do this i think i have
never done it actually in the history
of this show or any of my interviews i
usually don't like
when interviewers ask the audience for
questions for the interviewee
however i thought this was a special one
so i am taking one question
from the reuben report community to
directly
ask president trump i've got a couple
questions obviously i
have a specific direction i want to go
in this thing but i thought one question
from the audience so we already got
a couple hundred people throwing in
questions but if you would like to
submit
a question for me to ask president trump
tomorrow you can do that at
rubinreport.locals.com
and i'm just going to cover one story
today and then we're doing a q a and
it's a nice
broad mix of questions some personal
some political some cultural
and a whole bunch of other stuff uh and
then i'm just gonna
tell you one little thing about that joe
biden guy he is very very
very very very very confused but before
i do that guys i want to talk to you
about raise american you know i'm
thrilled
to welcome raise american as a new
sponsor to the show
a company who raises the bar for premier
organic grass-fed beef from all over the
country
for more than 15 years raise american
has been honing its processes
to provide lovers of beef the ultimate
eating experience from the feed to the
cattle to the state
raise american raises the standard of
what american organic beef ought to be
raise american cattle come from humanely
treated animals reared on small
independent american farms farms run by
family farmers and ranchers
adhering to some of the strictest animal
welfare and sustainable farming
protocols
healthy cattle make healthy beef and no
one knows that better than the team that
raised american raised american focuses
on sustainability
which is why they work closely with
these family farms to raise grass-fed
organic cattle which spend most of their
lives grazing pastures in the open
fresh air grazing in a way that
regenerates the soil instead of
depleting it
raise american is 100 organic 100
grass-fed 100 american
go to raise american dot com right now
in order to learn more
uh order and learn more good for you
good for our planet good for america and
now back to me and as i said yesterday
you don't even need a code no code ruben
because they're only advertising with us
right now because they love what we do
and by the way i've been showing you
some of the meat that they've been
sending us here my
my big meet while i've got a ton of
family and friends visiting we're going
to be basically running a hotel here for
a couple days
and we're busting out the prime rib
tonight so stay tuned for some pictures
on that
uh all right so i want to show you some
video of joe biden yesterday talking
about gun control and i know
joe is confused and joe is not the man
he
was say 10 20 30 years ago and that he's
not really in charge
and that he's far more radical than my
good decent liberal friends thought they
thought
oh he would stop the crazies but the
crazy is here the crazy has just run
amok
and has taken over everything well
yesterday biden
made a gun control argument that i think
is the best ever argument
for the second amendment but he was
doing it as an argument sort of against
the second amendment
take a look the second amendment from
the day it was passed
limited the type of people could own a
gun and what type of weapon you could
own
you couldn't buy cannon those who say
the blood of the
the blood of patriots you know and all
the stuff about how we're going to have
to
move against the government well the
tree of liberty is not water with the
blood
of patriots what's happened is that
there are
never been if you wanted to think you
need to have weapons to take on the
government
you need f-15s and maybe some nuclear
weapons
the point is that there's always been
the ability to limit
rationally limit the type of weapon that
can be owned
and who can own it oh joe
poor muddled joe struggling with the
teleprompter and everything else all
right first off
we do always limit who can buy guns well
first off we do have some limits right
now
uh right so you know certain psychiatric
patients people with criminal histories
things of that nature that's why we have
background checks
and there are background checks
everywhere and if you would like to
argue
how effective those background checks
are that would just be fine but when
they make it seem like you can just walk
into a gun shop and get a gun
you simply cannot as you guys know i
bought some guns for the first time this
year and buying guns in california is
not very easy and there were weeks of
waiting and background checks
and all sorts of documents and you're
not going to believe this because of the
racism
i had to show an id i had to show an id
say that i am dave rubin
before they would actually give me the
gun but then the perverse part
of what old joe said there was in
essence the government's got
f-15s right the government's got nukes
so uh you're gonna need nukes if you're
gonna take us
that is the biggest sort of mafia move
that he could possibly ever make meaning
we're all powerful
we have the sort of ownership of
violence we the state
and you people uh you don't have access
to the weapons we have so
sit down and shut up that's exactly why
the founders put the second amendment in
right that's exactly why they did it
because they wanted us
to as the citizenry they wanted us to be
able
to say to the government hey if you guys
become too
tyrannical there's a bit of a threat
here that we have a bit of a threat i
don't want people running around with
guns in the streets
blowing up buildings and burning down
federal courthouses like they're doing
in portland that never gets seen on
cnn or msnbc or the other blue and on
channels i don't want that
but the average person of course should
be able to protect
their property their family and they
should be able to protect themselves
from a tyrannical government so if your
argument
is that we've got a lot of big weapons
so uh
you know you shouldn't be allowed to
protect yourself well actually that's
the best argument for us all having more
weapons
because i don't think that you should be
able to stop us from living freely joe
but you seem to think that you should be
able to anyway it's just such a
it's such a perfect example of that
everything
that the left says doesn't make sense
once you listen to it for two seconds
right so it like sort of makes sense at
the top like
and because i hear this from lefties all
the time i mean mainstream lefties it's
like
oh the government you know these people
want a militia so they can defend
themselves from the government the
government's got tanks the government's
got nukes the government's got f-15s
okay so what are you gonna do have all
those things i'm not for the average
person having all of those things
but is your point that the government is
just good because it has more weapons
than the rest of us
i don't think that's what makes things
just good i mean isn't the left always
talking about an asymmetry of power
and that that's the problem right the
oppressed and the oppressors and the
whole thing like
come on guys all right guys let's do a
little q a uh we got a ton of questions
at reubenreport.locals.com i asked my
guys to mix it up as always so it's not
just political
here we go kerry says happy almost
birthday dave any fun plans for the
birthday
thanks for everything you do yes i am
going to be 45 on saturday
june 26th and we are having a massive
party here we're having about a hundred
people here
there's going to be sushi and catering
and tequila
and basically there's every booze you
can possibly imagine is in my house
right now
we're going to have a lot a lot of
family a lot of friends it's going to be
sort of a weekend
extravaganza i've got places basically
basically gonna be running uh we're
gonna be running a hotel
over here with uh with brothers sisters
and cousins and friends and a lot of
former guests and you know people you
guys all know from the show
and i haven't had a birthday party we
were trying to figure it out like i
haven't had like a birthday party i
guess i've done like a dinner with a
couple that kind of thing
but like a legit birthday party since my
30th so that was 15 years ago and i
don't even remember
what i did before that really so uh yeah
we're going to be doing a little
celebrating
cali is open thanks to emperor gavin
newsom and
you know fortunately we've got a nice
house where we can host a whole bunch of
people and it's
beautiful weather so we're going to be
outside and drinking and
eating and have a good time and we've
got a photographer coming so maybe
you'll see
some of the pictures and actually we'll
definitely post some stuff at least in
the reuben report community uh paul
says in your opinion is it more
important to keep desantis
in florida as governor or have him run
in 2024 for president
this is a really interesting question
because it's like on one hand i think
you can definitely make the argument
that that guy
just solidifying florida making the
right
choices in florida keeping the state
open getting critical race
theory out you know doing the things
economically so that a guy like me can
go down to miami and talk to a great
mayor in france suarez will put that up
next week
where you know that business is
flourishing like that's not disconnected
a good mayor
there who happens to be a conservative
that's not disconnected from the good
governor who happens to be a
conservative
um so i think there's a real argument
that if the states are to survive
you need the best people at the helm of
the states like as the governors
of the states that's good on the other
hand the argument that we do need
somebody to run this country you know to
be the top of the ticket
that is making some sense uh that that's
pretty important too
even if in my world that president
wouldn't have that much power
so i think you can argue this either way
but the way i will argue it is that
i think desantis has got to run for
president my guess
is that he will my guess is that trump
and maybe i'll talk to trump about this
tomorrow
my guess is that trump will sort of
offer some defense on that and help with
the rallies and fighting the media that
that to me
is the great ticket i mean i've said it
before but you just let
desantis be the statesman he knows the
issues
um he's younger he's ready to fight like
he's
he's in it let him do all that and man
imagine if trump just acted like the
bodyguard
for the media and the [ __ ] like
there is a powerful move right there and
then you figure out who he's gonna run
with is he gonna run with
nikki haley is he gonna run with tim
scott is he gonna run with kandace owens
is he gonna run with
whoever dan crenshaw does it doesn't
even matter at some level
but it's because you've got like a broad
swath of people that he can choose from
and then you've got a really tight
ticket
and then of course what i would want to
happen concurrently with that is that
you got to get some other good people
in florida maybe trump then runs for
governor or florida i mean i think
anything is possible at this point
in case you didn't know it we're in a
great time of uncertainty so
quite literally anything is possible uh
nathan says do you know anyone who you
share the same birthday with
mine is tomorrow so just one day off
from yours well happy birthday nathan
number one
uh the two people who popped to mine on
june 26 for me are derek jeter who of
course was
was on the yankees you know 90s into the
2000s one of the greatest
shortstops to ever play the game and
then a lesser-known athlete jerome
kersey who was on the portland
trailblazers
in the in the early 90s then he was on
the he was on the spurs and i think the
sonics and the lakers for a season
and he actually passed away a couple
years ago he's really one of my favorite
players never made an all-star team
a really excellent role player this guy
just knew how to run
and work hard real workhorse those are
the only two can we get some other june
26th birthdays all right michael is
going to get me some other june 26
birthdays while i
plow ahead sherry says
uh i'm curious about the california
recall efforts who's the frontrunner are
they recalling the insane da's
in san francisco and in l.a uh what
happened with garcetti in the ambassador
post and if he does
take it or is he uh or if he's offered
it what happens in la so from what i
understand
garcetti has accepted the ambassador
post to india so we're getting rid of
that buffoon he's being shipped off to
india
good luck india i know i have a lot of
fans in india we get a lot of messages
from india and i just want to say
i'm sorry i had nothing to do with this
and
nothing good will come out of that
relationship because he's not a good man
so good luck with all of that as for the
recall
it is happening 1.7 million people
signed it and despite the democrats best
efforts
they were unable to reverse it
interestingly get this
so this morning i was watching a
documentary on thomas jefferson while i
do cardio i try to watch
like some historical stuff and just not
certainly not the news right
so i'm watching this really wonderful
documentary on thomas jefferson and the
founding of the country and you know his
political beliefs and all this stuff
and then a youtube video pops up in the
middle the whole thing about thomas
jefferson's about freedom and
all of this stuff and then a youtube
video pops up in the middle and it's an
anti-recall commercial
and in the commercial it's basically
like these you know it's the same old
nonsense that the
that the left does with everything
right-wing republicans are
trying to gain power by you know
reversing the election and getting rid
of
gavin newsom and right-wing far right
you know
just the usual nonsense at the end of
the commercial because it wasn't a
skippable commercial
um it said that it was funded by reed
hastings
i didn't know who that was but i was
like that name rings a bell who's reid
hastings and i googled it reed hastings
is the ceo of
netflix isn't that interesting so the
ceo
of netflix is funding commercials
to stop the recall kind of tells you all
you need to know about sort of the
corrupt media hollywood world and those
people why would they
want why would reid hastings i'm
guessing he might live in california or
at least
at one time there was a lot of
production done out of california why
would he want
newsom to still be governor after the
way that they've wrecked california and
wrecked los angeles i mean i think there
are reasons that they would want it
because he's
pushing the propaganda that you know
these guys like couple other birthdays
uh on june 26th ariana grande she's the
one that didn't she lick a donut or
something remember there was a
you know what i'm talking about right
there's a video i think of ariana grande
she's like a young singer right and she
licked a donut you got to google this
thing
she goes into a store a donut shop and
just licks the donut i don't know what
she sings but i remember seeing the
video of her licking a donut
yeah oh yeah she says she grabs a donut
from like like she just walks into the
donut shop she grabs donut licks the
donut and says i hate america she's a
great american hero
aubry plaza from parks and rec i don't
know who she is
uh nick offerman from parks and rec i
don't know who he is
i've never seen pip parks in iraq and
jeanette mccurdy from
icarly which i don't know who she is or
that show
uh long story short it's me and jeter
we're the big two for uh for june 26th
as for the other questions you asked
about the recall yes i believe
that there is a recall in place for
chesa bodine who is the d.a
in san francisco i believe that there is
a recall in place
for the ridiculous george gascon who was
our d.a in la who was the former d.a of
san francisco
who these people just ruined things
they're cockroaches wherever they go
they ruin things please
show me somebody somebody for my
birthday
for my birthday could somebody show me a
place
where progressive policies are put into
place where progressive politicians take
over
where anything remotely good happens
could you show me
that place that utopia could it doesn't
exist it doesn't exist but that would be
the greatest birthday present i could
possibly get
danielle says we all know you love meat
but side dishes what are your some of
your favorites and care to share any
recipes
well actually you can go so my husband
david is actually working on a cookbook
right now
and if you want to see some of the
recipes that he's working on
some of them will be in the book but
obviously he's i think he's doing about
100 in the book
probably about 20 on the website right
now you go to davidscookbook.com
or you can see more of it at
instagram.com
david's cookbook and he's just an
incredible chef who just loves
like all sorts of different foods
he culturally appropriates the hell of
hell out of food by the way he cooks all
sorts
of stuff he's not indian but he cooks
india and he's not latino but he cooks
latino
he's not italian but he cooks italian he
cooks all sorts of stuff
what can i tell you that's on there
that's great it's well there's a lot of
meats a lot of chickens
oh he makes some baked fries that are
amazing like if you want a healthy fry
that will taste
like you got it from your favorite fast
food joint
even better than that that's not soaked
in oil and the rest of it there's a
recipe
at davidscookbook.com for baked fries
you should definitely try it out
uh eileen says if you could be president
what would be your top three issues
you'd like to tackle to start well i
know for sure
my main message as president
would be i can't help you i can't help
you
i've got my own problems i don't know
what your problems are
frankly i don't care but what i will do
as president is i will surround myself
with a couple people who actually don't
want to do that much either
they can't do that much good and they
can't do that much bad yes we'll protect
the borders of the united states we'll
make sure we've got a functional army
but pretty much beyond that we're going
to cut all the budgets
we're going to we're going to give you
all your money back we're going to cut
taxes
we're going to cut regulation we're just
going to get the hell out of your way
what right do we have to be running your
lives so i don't know that there's three
things that i would really want to do
i don't know three things i really want
to do i'd blow up the department of
education how about that
let's do that i'd get rid of teachers
unions is that even something the
president could do i would well the
president can do anything now he's got a
pen
and a paper and they you know they let
you do anything so that's pretty good
my slogan would be help yourself my son
would be get off my lawn
my slogan would be i don't like you like
what do you want me to do
that that really is it you know ronald
reagan it's that it's that great quote
the worst eight words
that you can ever hear are i'm from the
government and i'm here to help
like that's it these people can't do
anything what would you want the
government
doing for you absolutely nothing just
give people their money back
you know one of the things that's really
fascinating this gets to
one of the questions earlier about gavin
newsom in the recall is that newsome
right now knows because of the recall he
has to do all sorts of stuff so suddenly
the homeless thing
homeless people are disappearing i don't
know what they're doing they're putting
them in black bags and throwing them out
in the river i have no idea what they're
doing
but even where i live here where there's
a huge homeless problem
the underpass that we have where they've
been building this like homeless
you kind of got to marvel at it they're
building like multiple level tents and
all sorts of stuff
but in the last week or so it
disappeared where there were like
dozens and dozens of homeless
encampments and tents and all these
things
so newsom is realizing that there's
suddenly pressure
on him to do something and he doesn't
want to get recalled so he starts doing
the right thing
and even he's talking about things like
tax rebates suddenly and it's like oh
wait a minute
you think so you think that people
having more of their money is good then
stop taking
more of their money in the first place
you ridiculous fraud
yeah my line would be you you deserve a
refund
you know what do you want me to do about
it that would really be it i can't help
you
i've got my own problems that really is
it like if if we had a government that
did that but you know protect the
borders
make sure the states aren't at war with
each other um
we don't need big government agencies to
really do anything
uh that would pretty much be it and i
think things would be a lot better
anna says when are you moving to florida
oh man so
look i know everybody wants me to move
to florida i'm obviously thinking about
it
we just moved locals down there my
partner in locals is my brother-in-law
so my sister
and the kids just moved down there my
folks have a place in florida i love
florida yes it was a little humid but i
i've always loved florida actually
that's that's where we always went on
vacation when i was a kid
so you know it's probably going to
happen at some point i also
manage a couple other businesses and i
have employees and all sorts of stuff
but obviously for tax reasons
for quality of life reasons for living
in a place who
where there are people whose ideals i
share
as opposed to here where i go into the
yesterday i went into the supermarket
and it's like still half the people are
wearing masks
and i'm looking at them like you're
crazy you're crazy people now granted
they're probably looking at me and going
you're crazy so we're just at like a
crazy impasse here
um but yeah when i was in florida to sit
down with the mayor down there
mayor suarez in miami and then i met uh
mayor grossman of bell harbor
we had lunch and just to talk to all the
people and we did a reuben report
hangout so
uh we did a hangout with the locals
community a couple dozen people showed
up to a bar
and everyone is so friendly and happy
and you know they i always tell you
people always want to touch me so
there's a lot of hugging and then it's
very sweaty and all that but we're all
okay
nobody nobody dropped dead anything like
that um
so yeah we'll see you we'll see but look
i think for now
the best i can tell you is i want the
recall to happen and then let's just see
but yeah there's not much left here
there's not uh stan says how do we beat
critical race theory
uh like in the luden county school so
there's this really crazy video
of a meeting a school board meeting
where some parents come in to fight
critical race theory and then one of the
fathers ends up getting arrested a
little of the
some of the details are unclear this was
just from yesterday i was doing a lot of
things but i did see the
a quick portion of the video how do you
beat critical race theory you
show up even if it's if it feels bad and
you don't want people to say mean things
about you and they're gonna
you know drag you out of there like they
did to this father you show up
at these meetings and you do not let
your children be indoctrinated
into evil ideas if they were teaching
nazism
at your children's school would you let
that happen
this is pretty damn close and i know
that sounds hyperbolic and
congratulations media matters you just
got your clip of the day
uh dave rubin compares critical race
theory to nazism yes
dave rubin does because nazism was race
essentialism nazism was the idea
that your immutable characteristics were
something that should be punished or
some people's immutable characteristics
the white aryan race were better than
other people and we're going to put
jews in camps and we're going to put
gays in camps and gypsies in camps
they didn't really love black people
either hitler was not a huge fan of
black people
so i would not want nazism taught in
school the same way i would not want
critical race theory
taught in school for all the reasons
that you know about okay you know you
are not
born evil because you are white you are
not born better because you are black
and america was not founded on the idea
of racism
these are things we just would not teach
i'm not i'm not for banning the idea you
want to go to a party and hang out with
a bunch of critical race theorists guess
what you're going to hang out with a
bunch of freaking
miserable people with no joy
and and really no no ability to create
or do anything fun
but you should do that but show up stand
up guys
if you're not exactly sure what i'm
talking about watch my last prageru
video from a couple months back called
the bravery deficit and just get brave
get brave because if you don't nobody
else will and i would suspect that when
you're 90 and you look back on your life
and you go man i didn't speak up and
then my son got brainwashed and my
daughter got brainwashed and the country
collapsed you go maybe i
maybe i should have done something i
don't know peter says while the other
questions are extremely important
i put this as an immediate need as a
locals community
can we help the florida families of the
collapsed building oh
yeah i'm really glad you asked this so i
just saw a picture of this this morning
so the surfside condo in florida i think
it's somewhere in miami it's near miami
if i'm not mistaken
it's in miami uh collapsed and i think
as
of right now there are 51 people who are
missing
in the rubble which is just unbelievably
horrible uh
there has been a gofundme organized by a
guy
by the name of zack sohn they've raised
16 000 so far
i'll donate can you make sure that we
take care of that i'm going to donate
i'll donate 100 bucks right after this
um and we'll post the gofundme link and
we do that in the description here we
will post the gofundme link
these people obviously are gonna need
help this is it's a really uh horrific
situation i'm not gonna bother showing
you guys any pictures or anything right
now
thank you for mentioning that one uh
ross says i was red pill just over a
year ago and realized i have unknowingly
held conservative values all along
i work in creative fields dominated by
lefties and now see why i didn't quite
fit in
my old friendships with these people are
hanging on by a thread as i see their
propaganda on social media
how can i be my true self and deal with
our differences if you work in a
creative field i want you to think about
this
this is your opportunity whatever it is
if you're a musician
if you're a painter if you're a sculptor
if you're a comedian if you're an actor
whatever it is
use this use this your truth is being is
being
uh slammed up against this evil woke
orthodoxy of the day
those people because they have chosen a
cult
that tells them what to think and when
to think and how to think
because of that they cannot be creative
they cannot make great art that's why
all the tv shows suck
that's why all the movies now suck
that's basically why everything kind of
sucks right now when's the last time you
heard great new music i'm not
sitting here saying that none of it
exists but we're in a
we're in a time when there's just like a
black hole of creativity
and if you're a creative person i know
that it sucks to lose those friends
everyone watching this knows it sucks to
lose those friends i promise you
dave rubin guaranteed 100 promise
you will find other friends on the other
side
and if your friendships are hanging on
by a thread and it's because
the only reason that that threat hasn't
fully frayed is because you're really
not saying what you think well then what
kind of friendships are those
friendships are hey this is who i am
that's who you are
let's do the dance and let's do this
over decades actually this weekend
i have my two best friends of my life my
buddy john we met the first day of
kindergarten
and i've been arguing with him about
politics and playing video games and
sports
with him for now 41 years he's coming
this weekend my buddy harry who moved to
town
in third grade who was probably my my
greatest political opponent
over life and now over time we've come
together but we used to debate it out
from
high school and same social studies
classes in college and beyond
he's coming out this weekend find
friends that
that enrich your life i know it sucks
and i know it feels like you won't get a
job in the creative field and all of
that stuff and i'll tell you two quick
things
of friends of mine in the creative thing
and how you can suffer in it but why you
still got to do it i have a buddy who's
an award-winning
uh lighting guy okay he's done lighting
for us in some of our sets and things
uh he is emmy award-winning lighting guy
he happens to be i guess he's probably
about 65 and white he was told about a
year ago by the higher-ups at the studio
that he should basically look into an
early retirement because they're not
going to hire
just an old white guy anymore now he's
now doing some other things and gone a
little more independent
but the point is if you love something
this guy loves lights he loves lights
keep keep doing it you'll find a way to
do it the system's going to come after
you either way
and i've got a friend who is a broadway
choreographer
uh i'm going to end up giving him away
somehow because he's actually a straight
broadway choreographer i know that
sounds like an oxymoron this is a
straight
heterosexual man who is a broadway
choreographer that's the guy who teaches
them how to dance
he was told and this guy who's won
awards has done shows you've heard of
he was told that he should look into new
work because
they're not going to hire straight
people that his day is over he happens
to be white also but why would they
hire you know a middle-aged white
straight guy to teach dancing
you know when you can have a black trans
lesbian with a
lazy eye and a limp and you know a bum
shoulder and a
bad back like that's that that's the
future that's the future we've got to
accept it but the point is
create new things create new things if
you're creative you can do it rhiannon
says will there be an option to
subscribe to the entire locals app
it's simply too expensive for me to
subscribe to even three or four
communities so i just subscribed to this
one so
absolutely we're working on bundling i
can tell you one thing about
being in the tech world now uh and
helping run a company for the last
you know for the last two years of my
life you can't build everything at once
so we're working on it you know we have
to work with the end of our goal really
at first
was to just get everybody to be free
right build your community be free
but now we do see this people don't want
to subscribe to 10 different people and
the cost can add up and i don't want
locals to be cost prohibitive to anyone
so first off um
you know we'll i'll give away say 25
yearly subscriptions today if you're if
you're in the military
if you're struggling because of covet or
or something like that
if you email us uh at support
reubenreport.com
uh we'll we'll give away some some free
subscriptions today i can't i can't do
like an endless amount of it but i don't
want
cost to be part of it but yes we are
working on the bundling
option because in essence we can build
networks now you know we've got so many
great
people on locals you know tulsi
gabbard's on there and scott adams is on
there and michael malus is on there and
i'm on there and andy no it's like
you take those people right there you
got a cable channel so we're working
i may have said too much but we're
working on all sorts of stuff so
uh yes uh and i appreciate you being
part of what we're doing over there
patrick says dave for a constructive
debate both sides must speak in good
faith
is our problem today that the left
appears to be dishonest in their motives
while whatever we say they call us
racist thus questioning our motives
uh yes in essence yes that is that is a
huge problem look
i know that i joke around on this show
and i call these people
names sometimes and all of that stuff i
have tried i don't know
anyone really in a public sense that
tried for years to bring the two sides
together to honestly deal with what was
going on
on the left as a lefty as a guy that
formally supported bernie sanders and
should be judged as such
um but but it it didn't work the liberal
defense of leftism
did not work the liberals have collapsed
and because of that
all there really is on the left is a
group of people
who call everyone racists and bigots and
everything else and
if you want to see that they are unable
to debate i mean just watch chris ruffo
on joy read
yesterday i mean it's appallingly bad
it's appallingly bad as an interviewer
for her and just the
the understanding of the knowledge of
what she's talking about and the
judgment and all of those things and
it's like this is why like we may be
at an intractable place it's like for
all of uh like
if these people want giant collectivist
government
and huge governmental power to do
whatever it wants and take whatever it
wants and control all of us well
i don't want that and i don't think you
want that but but these are not really
things that can be negotiated these
things are so diametrically opposed
so you know a lot of people think oh
this is still like 1985 and it's
conservative thought
versus liberal thought let's say but the
but the basic rules there were that
america is pretty good and we can argue
about tax rates and everything else but
it wasn't like we're trying to destroy
everybody constantly
now we're in this destruction thing and
and the problem for us is
i actually would be okay and maybe the
way this all has to go
is that there has to be some sort of
real national separation i'm not talking
about breaking up the united states
but that we let's say the more freedom
liberty loving people will just build
different
things we will have we will truly send
our kids to different schools
we will hire differently based on skill
and not
diversity like all of those things we
will build a sort of parallel society
which i actually think is great it's
very much within the american tradition
and individualism and all that
the problem is our set of ideas won't
impede on their lives right because
we're not going to be going oh we're
building all our stuff and we want your
stuff
the problem with the lefties is well
first off they're going to build a bunch
of
racist backwards crap so they're not
even going to succeed
but as they're doing that they're
constantly going to want more from us
because we're going to succeed and we're
going to have more money and we're going
to thrive
and all of those things this actually is
very much what my next book is about and
it's like how do you mitigate that
how do you mitigate okay we have two
separate ideas here
we can kind of go in our different
directions in a modern world and still
remain part of the united states
but if one side's just like hey leave me
alone and the other side's like no
i want your [ __ ] and i want to control
you we have a problem i don't know
exactly
how to how to deal with that but i'll
keep talking about it final question for
the day
is landon what drink would you recommend
that
isn't soda and alcohol well as i said
we've got a lot of alcohol around here
right now
for this big party but um you know what
do a non-alcoholic paloma how about that
just get a little bit of grapefruit
juice uh some
lime juice and some club soda and just
splash a grapefruit splash of lime club
soda you got a non-alcoholic paloma
very refreshing pour it on ice and you
could do uh you could even do like a
little jalapeno in there something like
that and you
you will be very happy all right guys
part three
of my interview with michael knowles all
about his new book speechless which is
out right now is up on
the youtube and the full episode is up
at reubenreport.locals.com
as i said i am interviewing president
trump tomorrow
this is your last chance today to get
your question
one question from the community
reubenreport.locals.com
and there's not going to be a round
table tomorrow the trump interview is
the only thing
we're showing and as i said i got a lot
of family and friends coming for the
weekend so i'm going to
try to relax a little bit early but you
know trump interview we will see how the
relaxation goes that'll be something
uh anyway yeah it's my birthday weekend
so i intend on uh
relaxing and eating good food and
drinking good drink and being with
friends
and having fun and yeah we'll post some
pictures and videos and all that good
stuff
uh so thanks for watching and uh trump
tomorrow
and if you want to talk to me
reubenreport.locals.com
you